foreign
Chris is in Lansing Michigan hey Chris
how are you
hi Dave thank you for having me sure
um I am on baby step six and I kind of
have a two-part question
um my job security isn't too great right
now and I wanted to know should I wait
until I get a new job before I pay off
my house and if I didn't do that what
payments should I get rid of to work
towards paying down my house
what payments should you get rid of you
have other debt so
life and
life and um you know the edge 501 like
the educate 529 account tithing so those
are all you know
things that I pay in towards
um that maybe I could redirect towards
my house
okay
um no way baby step six we would tell
you to keep living your life and with
money you find in your budget you would
pay extra on your house
uh it sounds like this job thing's got
you rattled
how long you been working there
well it's my company so for 20 years
and I have a business partner
okay
um so you're not gonna lose your job you
might lose your business is what you're
saying
yes if one of us
um doesn't leave and I'm the main
contributor
and it's not enough to support
both of us
so slowly
um
my income has gone way down to a point
where I can't really afford not to leave
and he's not leaving so I'm going to
look for something different
what do you do
um it's a marketing company
okay are you married to your business
partner
no no but I am divorced
used to be married to your business
I'm sorry
did you used to be married to your
business partner
no no okay so how is your business
partner squashing your ability to earn a
living
um because he's not contributing and
we're 55
. so he's not bringing in his side of
the business yet he's taking half of
what you bring in and since he's not
bringing any in the the total pie is has
shrunk and he's taking it keeps you from
closing the doors and opening a door
next door and just doing this on your
own and making all the money
um our partnership agreement
I basically wouldn't be able to do that
um you have to buy out in order to get
out you have to buy out
uh no you have to he'd have to buy you
out
if you want to know that's not how our
partnership agreement is structured our
apartment A partnership agreement is
structured that if you leave
um you buy your clients if you were to
take them
but I'm looking to get out of this
industry all together and start just a
whole different chapter okay so what are
you going to do and what are you going
to be making
um well I'm looking right now but I'm
hoping to
um manage a team of people and be in
sales and
um I'm looking at
around
200 to 350.
Okay so
um this sounds like it didn't just
suddenly occur it's it's crept up on you
and you've you've put off making the
decision
correct you've delayed and so what you
need to do is not worry about your house
and not worry about your tithe you need
to get on the phone today and get a
freaking job Chris it's time to do this
painter get off the ladder today yeah
you you you're you're a year
at least maybe six months late on
someone kicking you and I'm gonna kick
you right now because I love you get
going I'm probably about five years to
ten years later okay then then somebody
needs to break the fog up so I'm your
guy I love you enough okay get going
girl okay you're too sharp to be this
dumb get going get going let's go go I
want you to have this done by the end of
April a new job and say bye bye
April yep you got a month
I got it check out my resume ready you
need to call me back on the air and tell
me you did it I'm gonna hold you
accountable okay
okay
and you need to call uh who is your best
girlfriend that's mean
say it say your name say your name
Girlfriend yes you do yes you do who how
many okay what about your sister she
mean
no I want somebody mean I want you to
call them and tell them to call you and
kick you if you don't do this I want you
to declare to the world it's time for
you to Roar again Chris you're meowing
yeah I understand I know that and you
are not a kitten you are a lioness
Am I Wrong understood this thing was
built up by a woman
this whole thing was built up by a woman
of substance
this was built by a woman of substance
and yet you have for some reason you
have watched this thing deteriorate and
your life with it to the point now
you're going I don't know if I need to
pay for groceries no you need to get a
freaking job
I know this is what's going on yeah go
get that and all of these other
questions go away don't they
you're 100 percent
that's why I'm here
if you if hey something I don't hear at
home very often you keep answering
questions like this you're gonna turn
this into a job
yeah
so stuck in just the day to the day that
sometimes you just take someone looking
at you like what are you doing
you can solve all of it all of it let's
get trapped but you you do need ah you
really need people in your life in your
community that are that love you enough
to go uh I'm watching you do nothing and
I'm tired of it there's that famous uh
psychological study where they took the
dogs and you couldn't do this study now
but they shocked them and
um
they they didn't give them an
opportunity to escape and they had other
dogs that they were shocked that they
would allow to escape and over time they
would take the barriers off the dogs
that they were shocking the dogs just
took it it was just learned helplessness
this is the way this is going to be and
it just you need somebody to go hey go
go you can run and run away then they
take off right just gotta get somebody
to look at you so that's the fun thing
so yeah
um we all need that though because what
the the fastest way I mean that's
classic uh frog and a kettle thing I
mean fastest way to boil a frog is turn
it up one degree at a time just a little
bit of time gradual gradual five years
this has been deteriorating and then you
look up and you go wait a minute I'm
boiling over here yeah
and this guy's doing nothing and still
collecting half the
house because I'm trapped in a really
stupid partnership agreement hey
I hear this happen a lot people have an
imaginary amount of money they're gonna
make when they leave their job how how
tightly do you tell somebody to hold on
to that versus get something and then
begin to maneuver and this one gets
something and then begin to maneuver
yeah but um 253 just like I've been
doing this job for 20 years I'm just
gonna transition
she might I mean in this current
environment where there's such a
shortage of everybody high quality White
Collar people I mean yeah it's she might
I don't know I don't know what her skill
set is but uh urgency is one of them we
got to add back to it yeah yeah here we
go